the second wave of kovat 19 will start
somewhere not everywhere a local
outbreak that get out of hand and
spreads so new research by Sky News is a
concern we've looked at the trends in
infection rates in local authorities
across England and Wales and they show
that in Blackburn with Darwen the rate
in the first two weeks of July was 34
percent up on the previous fortnight in
pendel the virus was spreading even
faster up 54 percent but our analysis
shows how quickly lockdown works
although Leicester still has the largest
number of cases for the size of its
population rates fell by 20 percent
other researchers have looked back at
the impact of the national lockdown
scientists at Imperial College London
tested more than 120,000 random people
across England in May these weren't
people who are in hospital or in care
homes these were in the community so
that people most affected by the
restrictions on everyday life and the
researchers found the virus was in rapid
decline with cases harvick every eight
or nine days which puts the are number
at 0.57 well below the threshold of one
above which of course the epidemic
starts to grow
now that's lower than the estimate by
government scientists at the time they
put it at between 0.7 and 0.9 but that
included care homes where the virus
continued to spread at a high rate for
longer overall 13 in every 10,000 people
in England tested positive for the virus
in May rates were highest in young
people 27 cases in every 10,000 compared
to just seven in 10,000 in the over 65
they're more likely to have been
isolating people of Asian ethnicity were
also more likely to be infected with 24
cases in every 10,000 now strikingly 69%
of those testing positive didn't have
any symptoms in the week before their
test it underlines that many people
aren't even aware they're infected so
continue their normal daily activity and
they wouldn't be picked up by the test
and
system and that significant concern when
we're trying to keep a lid on such a
highly infectious virus